hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
arrow just confirm two big new
characters one is gonna be the
antagonist another is going to be a
friend but they're both very Punisher
like characters so I'll explain what's
going on they're doing like a cross
between the wire is a little daredevil
season 2 so Oliver Queen versus The
Punisher what the hell does that mean
well they have a new character coming on
called vigilante that's his name in the
comic books
who's the district attorney whose family
gets gunned down and he seeks vengeance
by gunning down the assailants turning
into a Punisher type character but more
of an antagonist the way he was used in
the comics he's a Marv Wolfman character
so he's a bit of a deep cut but the way
he's used is a little more hardcore
version of The Punisher
and we're talking Punisher war zone
Punisher max so it's a character who
starts out really good ends up crossing
the line and Oliver Queen will have to
stop him
so we have one new vigilante in the city
that's kind of bad even though he's
trying to do good things now like The
Punisher for instance he kills his
villains so he's a bit of a wild card
but you watch daredevil season 2 and you
see that there's a lot of heart in there
he's actually a good person he's not a
villain the way they're describing this
new District Attorney arrow character
he's going to be more of an antagonist
like they won't come together as much as
daredevil and Punisher come together
during the series so I'm not really
thinking of him as the main villain but
he will be the main antagonist he'll be
a really big character that will be on
all season and obviously because Oliver
Queen is mayor now he'll be interacting
with the district attorney as Oliver
Queen and then later after he becomes
this vigilante Oliver will be butting
heads with him at night as Green Arrow
mister terrific made a joke about Star
City last season where he was like three
disasters in three years I was ready to
get the F out
but then he was inspired by Green Arrow
and the team arrow and all the things
that they were doing so he stayed now
he's gonna be something more of a hero
so you have a city that's been in crisis
for three or three big disasters imagine
what it takes what kind of fortitude
like the kind of person that would be
willing to still continue to live in the
city so this new district attorney comes
along seems like a good person
upstanding member of the community doing
good putting villains away but then his
family gets gunned down punisher style
turning him into something of a punisher
revenge killing all the criminals in the
city bad news is
and have that so Oliver Queen versus the
Punisher but there's another new
character they confirmed who is also a
vigilante
his name is wild dog he's kind of like a
cross between sports master from the
comics in Omar from the wire just to
someone whose superpower is guns he like
he goes around gunning down villains but
it's not quite as negative as this
District Attorney storyline like he ends
up joining team arrow they say that
Oliver's gonna take him under his wing
so imagine if Omar from the wire became
the new Roy Harper just like somebody
that Oliver took under his wing look you
don't have to kill people you can still
do good for the city without gunning
everyone down all the time so we
basically have to Punishers that go down
a dark path one continues down that dark
path another this wild dog character
listens to the voice of reason and
starts to do good by the city so already
if you haven't done it you have to watch
daredevil season to watch The Punisher
arc especially the first couple of
episodes that he's in breeze butting
heads with daredevil
that's gonna be like Oliver versus this
vigilante character in season 2 then
like the later episodes of daredevil
where Punisher actually starts helping
daredevil a little bit they start
working together that will be more of
like the wild dog characters art so I
think if you're not a big comic book
person it's just really easy to think
about Punisher on daredevil season 2 the
way he worked with that characters
motivations were what it drove him to do
and the consequences of that now the
difference with arrow is is that we have
twice as many episodes so you're gonna
get to see the good version it'd be like
seeing Frank Castle before he became the
Punisher then slowly is gonna be driven
to all these revenge killings so your
homework for arrow season 5 is daredevil
season 2 you should also watch The Wire
a little bit if you're not familiar with
the Omar character he's a bit of a wild
card he's not one side or the other he's
just a vigilante that's willing to gun
down drug dealers so he just calls it
part of the game part of the game yo all
just part of the game so what about the
other characters team arrow essentially
broke up now you see why they have so
many new characters coming in because
team arrow is fractured so Oliver will
have all this free time to Train this
wild dog character I don't know when the
rest of team arrow is gonna come back to
Star City but Diggle looks like he
re-enlisted so he's gonna be gone for a
little while then you have felicity who
got fired last season so she might try
to form her own company she's a bit of a
question mark Thea also a question mark
she looks like she's been on vacay
and John Barrowman will come back but I
don't know for how many episodes I don't
think he's gonna be as big as he was in
previous seasons because most of this
energy is gonna be spent developing
these new vigilante characters which I
actually think is a really good thing so
if you were bummed out by a lot of the
soapy elements from arrow season for
like the soap opera elements I really
feel like it's gonna play more like a
traditional crime drama in season five
so if you like The Wire if you like
daredevil season two you'll probably
have a lot of fun during arrow season
five but let me know in the comments
what do you think about the dynamic
changing between Oliver in the city like
now he is the man he's in charge and he
sees vigilantes doing things that he was
trying to do only they're crossing the
line so he has to stop them so now he's
on both sides of the conflict he's still
green arrow at night trying to clean up
the city but he's the mayor during the
day so expect them to have some fun with
that dual life but if you have read the
run of green arrow comics where Oliver
Queen was mayor of Star City a lot of
that story line has already been used by
arrow so as is the case in the past it's
gonna be different from the comics but I
do recommend you check out Green Arrow
rebirth if you want to read Green Arrow
comics because even though DC rebirth is
really awesome flash rebirth is awesome
all the rebirth tiles are a lot of fun
Green Arrow rebirth number one was
actually one of their top selling issues
so be sure to check it out but it's not
gonna have anything to do with the TV
show just like flash rebirth isn't gonna
have anything to do with flash season 3
it's you know completely different comic
books TV shows totally different so
because it is the summer though I will
be doing more comic book videos so if
you guys want me to do green arrow
rebirth I might combine those with my
flash rebirth videos so be sure to
subscribe to get everything actually I
should start a new round of the giveaway
now so new round of the giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's
just a $20 Amazon gift card I'll
announce the winner when I post my next
DC video while you guys wait for new
Game of Thrones to post this weekend you
can click here for my new Civil War 2
video bulk killing the Marvel Universe
and you can click here for my new flash
season 3 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight